in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions drew
and Farrah are with us hey how are you
guys
we're doing great babe how are you
welcome good to have you so where do you
guys live
we're from Cincinnati Ohio welcome to
Nashville
thank you it's a lovely city and you're
here to do your debt-free screen yes yes
how much have you paid off we paid off
$200,000 in five years very cool and
range of income during that time we
started with an income of 64,000 gross
five years ago and last year in 2015 we
grossed 130,000 way to go what do you
guys do for a living we're both federal
employees so we work for the Department
of Defense I'm a contract negotiator and
I'm a recruiter and then we also beam
ghazal intents started up a bunch of
side companies and some side work and
just going at it as much as we could
over those period of years
cool very good well yeah you've doubled
your income there so what kind of debt
was the 200,000 a student loans it's one
of the big ones and then car payments
are current loans and then our house Wow
yes our house is fully paid off about
three weeks ago Wow way to go you paid
off your yes what's the house worth
house is about 140 150 made 133 four and
the rest of it is yes student loans car
payments and a credit card enhance you
did the whole thing how are you - 27 and
28 you are too young to have a paid-for
house that's just weird it's an amazing
feeling completely weird I love it so
tell me about this journey five years
ago what happened sure well we I don't
know we just started when we first got
married and when we got together we
started making really good money but we
I had my debt you know my student loans
my car she had her student loans her car
I was the spender and she was kind of a
natural saver but we were doing just
what every other American dies right and
well we make good money we just got
promoted or just got this or just got
that so we should go buy stuff yeah and
I we took your class we took financial
peace when we were engaged but
wasn't just the right timing and so as
one of your quotes you know is when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
and we took the class when we were
engaged but did just didn't work out at
the right time now were separated money
and we're not married yet we haven't
brought her stuff together six months
after we were married we're like yeah we
make great money but where's it at going
and we just started making some bad
decisions and yeah we I think we we're
on the same page you know we just one
day she's like you know you're the one
with the credit card and I just got this
new job and I just got promoted but like
nothing got any better so and then once
we started getting into it and got into
the debt snowball and everything it just
started becoming addicting to pay off
debt and we just picked up more side
jobs and I started a t-shirt company in
my basement let's start paying off debt
and I started doing web design and live
event production and concert production
and so that was kind of some of this
side income yeah I worked part time for
a church and he just became gizelle
intense and I think the first thing we
did was pay off a thousand dollars on my
credit card and she was kind of like hey
you should pay that off I've never had a
credit card that's terrible you need to
close that and so I did and it was like
whoa that was a quick win and shortly
thereafter Financial Peace University
materials back out off the shelf
oh yes yes exactly yeah after we were
married about six months and after
everything kind of came together we were
like what should we do and there was I
think it was like the 2009 version or we
look at it staring at us on our shelf
and were like well maybe we should do
Dave again and and we did and I never
looked back we've now taught financial
piece where coordinators at five times
at our church oh my goodness and so
we're we're changed in generations and
lives with you and God's help well thank
you thanks for doing that that's
incredible and now you got this great
story that you're not even thirty in
your class and people say gosh you paid
off everything house and everything
before you're 30 and they say how did
you do that what are you telling the
keys to getting out of debt are so
definitely the key for us is if we made
if you're made of making a hundred
thousand is living on 50 you know
just living unless your income and as we
got promotions and made more income it
all went to debt and our lifestyle never
change during that time so we're able to
do that and then contentment yeah yeah
and you know God's really changed us
during this time too and we love the
contentment he's shown us and what he's
molded us and to tearing this it's been
amazing
unreal I'm a whole bunch of growing up
going on yeah absolutely for sure it's
very cool there's I mean there's some
little things like sleeping on purchases
you know thinking about it talking about
and then waking up the next morning
realizing now we don't need that saying
no I was the spender I loved stuff I'm
hi I'm drew I like stuff but yeah I
think I think that was the biggest part
and as we start as we said with our
income you know what we practically and
we now have a house and two babies that
are right here our budget has
practically stayed the same our zero
based budget our expenses have pretty
much stayed the same
just because we doubled our income
doesn't mean that we go double our stuff
it just gives you margin to give and
margin to live sure you got we got the
room to do both you guys are incredible
very very well done you guys are heroes
I'm proud of you thank you very cool so
the babies ages and names Daisy and
she's 21 months and then we have a
scarlet who's nine months very year bar
we've got a Lydia that's about ten
months yeah that's about the perfect
image right there yes that's cool we'll
get them gathered up they got me in the
picture premiere drew and Farrah Daisy
and Scarlett $200,000 paid off that's
everything she's got on her be weird
t-shirts t-shirts a and the adventure
begin
did all of this in five years making 64
now making 130 from Cincinnati drew
Farah Daisy and Scarlett $200,000 paid
off house and everything counted down
let's hear a debt free screen 3 2 1
I love it that's the picture of a family
tree change right there oh that is fun
very well done you guys very very well
done man that's awesome
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind